can be only our
Victory the People Israel here in
America and in
Israel thank you very
[Applause]
much this is like the first time in my
life that I I I honestly don't really
feel safe being Jewish and we we felt a
bit nervous coming out here but we
thought you know we we can't let um that
fear kind of uh guide us we have to just
go out and and represent what we believe
in the anti-Semitism has always been
around if you want to get rid of
anti-Semitism you have to get rid of the
Jews and that will never happen
anti-Semitism always raises his ugly
head when there's a
conflict anti-israel is just another
name for
anti-Semitism I work in a city hall of
Philadelphia and there are constant uh
prop Palestinian protests and most of
them are young people who may or may not
realize what they're really protesting
about so they need to know that Jews
have been oppressed for centuries and
we're going to fight back although there
has been a rise in anti-Semitism uh
there are a lot of people who are
standing strong with the Jewish
Community it's unlike anything I've ever
seen before it's become so mainstream
and it's heart-wrenching to see the lack
of Consciousness in people's language
and processing what they're even saying
they don't know what they're saying yet
they say it anyways because it's cool
it's hip it's trendy and it's beyond
disturbing in my opinion that we have to
go to Such Great Lengths as a community
just to fight for our own Survival for
our right to exist if you support Hamas
you are an
anti-semite now it is so much F between
between light and darkness it's really
terrible cuz the fact that you post
about people who are kidnapped and they
say that then they say something about
Pro Palestine sometimes the issues
aren't the issues don't correlate just
because I'm talking about people who are
kidnapped I'm not talking about anything
else the fact that we when you respond
to people who are kidnapped you're
saying from from The River To The Sea
Palestine won't be free we're talking
about human lives here that were taken I
think uh the Jewish people we're we're
really uh we feel each other's pain very
deeply it is on the ride
we must confront it we must make sure
that people who commit anti-semitic acts
pay the price either legally or uh
economically and that's the only way to
tap this down it will never disappear
but we can reduce it to a dull Roar
living in New York City um there's a lot
of Jews there so um you know I haven't
seen that much personally other than
when I put posters up for the hostages
I've seen them taken down the
protest uh against Israel are a vocal
minority and that's all the M majority
of America stands with these people
right
here